On the 17th of May 2008, motorway patrol officers Cope and Finlayson responded to a call that a pedestrian had been hit by a vehicle on the M6 motorway near the city of Stoke-on-Trent in England. Expecting the worst, the two officers were surprised when they arrived on scene to see two pedestrians standing calmly and uninjured on the shoulder of the motorway. They didn't look like much was going on at all, but within a few minutes, the seemingly calm situation took a frightening twist. Hardly anything is known about the lives of twin sisters Sabina and Ursula Ericsson. They were born in Sweden on the 3rd of November 1967. They have an older sister Mona and an older brother
2008年5月17日，高速公路巡警科普（Cope）和芬l森（Finlayson）接到一起报警，称在英国特伦特河畔斯托克（Stoke-on-Trent）附近的M6高速公路上，一名行被车辆撞倒。两名警官做好了最坏的打算，但当他们赶到现场时，却惊讶地看到两名行人正平静且毫发无伤地站在高速公路的应急车道上。看起来似乎什么事也没发生，但在短短几分钟内，这起看似平静的事件却发生了一个令人毛骨悚然的转折。人们对双胞胎姐妹萨比娜（Sabina）和乌苏拉·埃里克森（Ursula Ericsson）的生活知之甚少。她们于1967年11月3日出生于瑞典。她们有一个姐姐莫娜（Mona）和一个哥哥
Bjorn. Whilst at school, the twins were described by summers a little bit odd. They kept mostly to themselves and at times they had a tendency to be violent. We know that in the year 2000, Ursula was living in the United States and Sabina was living in Ireland with her partner and two children. Nothing is really known about their lives though. From the year 2000 to the year 2008, it's believed that Sabina may have spent some time in the United States with Ursula and that her son even moved to the United States to live with Ursula for a period of time. For what reason we don't know. There is no evidence that either Sabina or Ursula had been treated for mental health issues. In 2008, Ursula visited Sabina in Ireland. It's not known if this was just a catch-up visit
比约恩（Bjorn）。在学校期间，双胞胎被人们形容为有点古怪。她们大多独来独往，有时有暴力的倾向。我们所知道的是，在2000年，乌苏拉在美国生活，萨比娜则与伴侣和两个孩子在爱尔兰生活。然而，人们对她们的生活并不真正了解。从2000年到2008年，人们认为萨比娜可能在美国和乌苏拉一起生活过一段时间，甚至她的儿子也曾搬到美国与乌苏拉一起生活过一段时间。具体原因我们不得而知。没有证据表明萨比娜或乌苏拉曾因心理健康问题接受过治疗。2008年，乌苏拉前往爱尔兰探望萨比娜。目前尚不清楚这只是一次普通的探亲
or if there was a specific reason for the visit. But what we do know is that during the visit, the twins were absolutely inseparable. They formed an extremely tight bond. And suddenly, in the early hours of the 16th of May 2008, without telling anyone of their intentions, Sabina and Ursula left Ireland. The twins were next seen the next day, the 17th of May, in Liverpool, England. It's believed they travelled to England from Ireland via ferry. The twins entered St Anne Street police station in Liverpool and Sabina reported concerns about the safety of her children. Why Sabina and Ursula travelled to England to report this when the children and her partner were back in Ireland is anyone's guess. Liverpool police contacted the police back in Ireland who
还是此行有着具体的原因。但我们所知道的是，在访问期间，这对双胞胎形影不离。她们建立了极其紧密的联系。突然间，在2008年5月16日的清晨，萨比娜和乌苏拉在没有告诉任何人她们意图的情况下离开了爱尔兰。这对双胞胎下一次被看到是在第二天，即5月17日，在英国利物浦。据信她们是从爱尔兰乘渡轮前往英国的。这对双胞胎进入了利物浦的圣安妮街（St Anne Street）警察局，萨比娜报告了她对孩子安全的担忧。至于为什么孩子和伴侣都在爱尔兰，萨比娜和乌苏拉却要为此事专门跑到英国来报警，这就不得而知了。利物浦警方联系了爱尔兰警方
did a check on Sabina's partner and the children. Everything was okay. Sabina's partner told the Irish police that Sabina had taken off after they had a fight. Irish police said Sabina and Ursula could get in touch with them if they had any fears or concerns upon their return to Ireland. After leaving St Anne Street police station, the twins boarded a National Express coach that was headed for London. They boarded the coach about 11.30am. The twins each had a bag and refused to put them in the baggage area of the coach. They insisted on holding onto the bags. Just after 1pm, the coach stopped at Kill Services, which is a service station on the M6 motorway. Details of why the coach stopped are a bit sketchy. There are reports that the coach stopped
对萨比娜的伴侣和孩子进行了核查。一切都好。萨比娜的伴侣告诉爱尔兰警方，萨比娜在他们吵架后离家出走。爱尔兰警方表示，如果萨比娜和乌苏拉在返回爱尔兰后有任何恐惧或担忧，可以随时与他们联系。离开圣安妮街警察局后，这对双胞胎登上了一辆开往伦敦的全国快运（National Express）长途客车。她们大约在上午11点30分登上了这辆客车。双胞胎每人都有一个包，并拒绝将它们放在客车的行李舱里。她们坚持自己拿着这些包。刚过下午1点，客车在M6高速公路上的基尔服务区（Kill Services）停了下来。关于客车停下的原因，细节有些模糊。有报道称客车停下
for a scheduled driver change. There's also reports saying that the only reason the coach stopped was because the twins were behaving erratically and causing trouble. Either way, the twins got off the coach despite the fact that it wasn't a scheduled rest stop. The driver was suspicious of them and ended up refusing to allow them back on the coach because the twins wouldn't allow him to search their bags. The driver told the employee in the service station, Melissa Dutton, that he wasn't letting the twins back on and basically told her it was her problem now, she could look after it. So Melissa kept an eye on the twins as well. She got suspicious of their behaviour. The twins were holding their bags tightly to
是为了例行更换司机。也有报道称，客车停下的唯一原因是因为这对双胞胎行为反常并制造了麻烦。无论如何，尽管这不是计划中的休息站，这对双胞胎还是下了车。司机对她们起了疑心，最终拒绝让她们重新上车，因为双胞胎不让他搜查她们的包。司机告诉服务区员工梅利莎·达顿（Melissa Dutton），他不会让双胞胎上车了，基本上告诉她现在这是她的问题了，由她来处理。于是梅利莎也一直盯着这对双胞胎。她对她们的行为起了疑心。这对双胞胎紧紧地把包抱在
their chest, like their lives were dependent on not letting go. That combined with the way they were talking and moving around, it looked like they were plotting something. Their behaviour actually led Melissa to think that maybe they were even carrying bombs in the bags. So Melissa called the police. Police did attend shortly after and spoke to the twins, but after checking them out, the officers didn't think anything was wrong. They told Melissa the twins were going to make their way to London and there were no issues. The police left the twins with a phone number for the coach company so they could arrange to get on the next coach. But instead of getting on another coach, the twins started walking along the M6 motorway.
胸前，就像它们的生命取决于绝不松手一样。这与她们说话和走动的方式结合在一起，看起来她们在密谋什么。她们的行为甚至让梅利莎怀疑她们的包里可能装着炸弹。于是梅利莎报了警。警方不久后赶到并与双胞胎交谈，但经过查验后，警官们认为没有什么不对劲。他们告诉梅利莎，双胞胎将前往伦敦，没有任何问题。警方给双胞胎留了一个长途客车公司的电话号码，以便她们安排乘坐下一班车。但双胞胎没有去坐另一辆车，而是开始沿着M6高速公路步行。
The M6 motorway is covered by video cameras, which are monitored at the Highway Agency's control centre in Birmingham. At about 3.20pm, the twins were spotted on the cameras walking along the central reservation of the motorway. There was a barrier on each side of them, but it was still dangerous. Not a place for pedestrians. A Highway Agency patrol unit was dispatched to get the twins off the motorway. Highway Agency officers aren't police. Their role is to basically ensure there are no issues on the motorways, to ensure traffic is flowing freely and there are no incidents that could put anyone at risk. If there is an accident, they will sort out the traffic management plan, put in roadblocks, diversions, things like that. They don't pull
M6高速公路覆盖有视频摄像头，这些摄像头由伯明翰的高速公路管理局控制中心进行监控。大约下午3点20分，摄像头拍到这对双胞胎正沿着高速公路的中央隔离带行走。她们两侧都有护栏，但这仍然很危险。这里绝不是行人该去的地方。高速公路管理局派出了一支巡逻小队将双胞胎带离高速公路。高速公路管理局的官员不是警察。他们的角色基本上是确保高速公路上没有问题，确保交通畅通，没有可能危及任何人的事故。如果发生事故，他们会整理交通管理计划、设置路障、疏导交通等。他们不负责
people over or issue speeding forwards. So a Highway Agency car was sent to get the twins out of the central reservation and off to safety. But when the twins saw the Highway Agency car, they jumped out of the central reservation and onto the motorway in front of oncoming traffic. Cars had to brake hard and swerve to avoid running the twins over. Sabina actually got clipped by a car and got knocked over. The incident was captured on video. Police and paramedics were immediately called to attend. The fear being Sabina could have serious injuries. But she didn't. She was perfectly fine. Her and Ursula made their way off the motorway and onto the shoulder.
拦下超速车辆或开罚单。因此，管理局派出一辆车将这对双胞胎带离中央隔离带，送到安全地带。但当这对双胞胎看到管理局的车时，她们跳出中央隔离带，冲上了迎面驶来的车流中的高速公路。汽车不得不紧急刹车和急打方向盘，以免撞到这对双胞胎。萨比娜实际上被一辆车擦了一下并被撞倒了。这一幕被视频记录了下来。警察和急救人员被立即召集到现场。人们担心萨比娜可能会受到重伤。但她没有。她完全没事。她和乌苏拉走下了高速公路，来到了应急车道上。
Police officers Cope and Finlayson responded to the call. And it just so happened that they had a camera crew with them who were filming for BBC's television show, Motorway Cops. When they arrived, the twins were still standing on the shoulder of the motorway. They were speaking with the two Highway Agency officers that first attended. Everybody was calm and there were no issues at all. The paramedics hadn't arrived yet. But by the looks of it, they wouldn't be required. Everything was calm and cool with no sign of anybody being injured. Officers Cope and Finlayson started talking with one of the Highway Agency officers to find out
警官科普和芬尔森赶到现场处理这起报警。碰巧的是，他们随行还有一个BBC电视节目《高速公路警察》（Motorway Cops）的摄制组。当他们到达时，这对双胞胎仍站在高速公路的应急车道上。她们正在与最早赶到的两名高速公路管理局官员交谈。每个人都很冷静，没有任何问题。急救人员尚未到达。但从外观上看，似乎不需要他们了。一切都平静祥和，没有任何人受伤的迹象。科普和芬尔森警官开始与其中一名管理局官员交谈，以了解
what was going on. The twins were a short distance away standing next to the other Highway Agency officer. Everybody was still standing on the motorway shoulder. Whilst the Highway Agency officer was still briefing the police, this happened. They were trying to cross the Bravers. Whilst we approached, they hadn't seen us really, the red ones got knocked down by the red tower over there. They've got an ambulance on route for them. Seems all right, but I'm not a doctor. She has been knocked down. Is he the one that speaks English or the other one? Michael for Michael, but we need ambulance, senior officers to the scene. We've got two
发生了什么事。双胞胎站在不远处，挨着另一名管理局官员。每个人都还站在高速公路的应急车道上。正当管理局官员还在向警察简要介绍情况时，事情发生了。她们试图穿过路障。在我们接近时，她们其实并没有看到我们，红色的那个被那边红色的塔撞倒了。他们已经为她们叫了救护车。看起来还好，但我不是医生。她被撞倒了。是那个说英语的还是另一个？麦克找麦克，但我们需要救护车，高级警官到现场。我们有两个
possible facels. The twins were standing there calmly. Nothing seemed out of the ordinary at all. Then suddenly, for no apparent reason, Ursula walked out onto the motorway. The Highway Agency officer nearby did his best, but he only managed to grab hold of a jacket, which she easily slipped out of. Ursula ran straight onto the road and directly into the side of a 40-ton truck. The truck ran straight over the top of her. Sabina then made her move, running out onto the motorway as well. She threw herself into the path of an oncoming car.
可能的面部朝下。双胞胎平静地站在那里。一切看起来都毫无异样。然后突然间，毫无明显原因，乌苏拉走上了高速公路。附近的高速公路管理局官员尽了最大努力，但他只抓住了她的一件夹克，而她轻易地从夹克里脱身了。乌苏拉径直跑向公路，直接撞在了一辆40吨重型卡车的侧面。卡车直接从她身上碾了过去。萨比娜随后采取了行动，也跑上了高速公路。她把自己扔向了迎面驶来的汽车前。
She went straight over the front of the car, smashing into the windscreen, denting the bonnet and the roof before being flung up into the air and then slamming hard onto the road. It's incredible footage. A link will be available in the show notes so you can see it. Your initial response is that there is no chance they would have survived that. But by some miracle, they both did. Both of them laid motionless on the road, knocked unconscious by the impacts, but they were alive. The motorway was immediately shut down and police went to work trying to render aid, while still waiting for the paramedics to arrive.
她直接翻过车头，撞碎了挡风玻璃，撞凹了发动机罩和车顶，随后被高高抛向空中，接着重重地摔在公路上。这是一段令人难以置信的画面。节目简介中将提供一个链接，供大家观看。你的第一反应是她们绝对不可能在那种情况下生还。但奇迹般的是，她们两个都活了下来。两人一动不动地躺在公路上，因撞击而失去知觉，但她们还活着。高速公路被立即关闭，警察开始设法提供援助，同时仍在等待急救人员的到来。
Officer Finlayson rushed to Ursula, who had been run over by the truck. She had massive leg injuries, suffering compound fractures. Ursula then started screaming out, saying she wanted the police. Even though it was a police officer kneeling next to her. She got quite aggressive and even started spitting and clawing at Officer Finlayson. Paramedics arrived shortly after. They made their way first to Ursula and helped calm her down, bringing her under control. Meanwhile, Officer Cote was with Sabina. Sabina was laying calmly until suddenly.
芬尔森警官冲向被卡车碾压的乌苏拉。她的腿部受了重伤，遭受了复合性骨折。乌苏拉随后开始尖叫，说她要找警察。尽管跪在她旁边正是一名警官。她变得相当具有攻击性，甚至开始向芬尔森警官吐口水和抓挠。急救人员不久后到达。他们首先走向乌苏拉，帮助她平静下来，将她控制住。与此同时，科特（Cote）警官正和萨比娜在一起。萨比娜一直平静地躺着，直到突然。
Where's Paul? Stay? Paul. Stay? Paul. Why do you feel me? Stay still. Why do you feel me?
保罗在哪里？呆着？保罗。呆着？保罗。你为什么摸我？保持别动。你为什么摸我？
I've got to get out of here. Fuck it all! No! No! Sabina stood up. Officer Cope was trying to get her to lay back down, trying to calm her down. Sabina started to pull away from Officer Cope. And then she turned around and punched her in the face,
我得离开这里。见鬼去吧！不！不！萨比娜站了起来。科普警官试图让她重新躺下，试图让她平静下来。萨比娜开始挣脱科普警官。然后她转过身，一拳打在她的脸上，
knocking her to the ground. Sabina then jumped over the central reservation and ran on to the other side of the motorway. Traffic was still moving, she was lucky she didn't get hit again. Officer Finlayson gave chase. Luckily the drivers could see what was going on and the traffic came to a stop.
把她打倒在地。萨比娜随后跳过中央隔离带，跑向高速公路的另一侧。交通仍在继续，她很幸运没有再次被撞。芬尔森警官随即追了上去。幸运的是，司机们能看到发生了什么，交通停了下来。
Officer Finlayson tried to get hold of Sabina. But Sabina took off her jacket and started jumping up and down, like she was shaping up for a fight. Stay! Stay there, calm down, calm down, calm down. Calm down. Okay, okay, calm down, calm down.
芬尔森警官试图抓住萨比娜。但萨比娜脱下夹克，开始上蹿下跳，就像在摆出打架的架势。呆着！呆在那儿，冷静，冷静，冷静。冷静。好的，好的，冷静，冷静。
Calm down. Yeah, calm down. Relax. Calm down. Chill. Calm down. We're police. Police.
冷静。是的，冷静。放松。冷静。镇定。冷静。我们是警察。警察。
Police, please. Police. I suspect this. Police. We're going to be on the bar for a day. Police. Police. Officer Coat, along with members of the public
警察，请。警察。我怀疑这个。警察。我们要被关一天了。警察。警察。科普警官与赶到的市民
and other police who had arrived, had to assist Officer Finlayson to bring Sabina under control. It took about six people in total. But even with that many people on her, she was still resisting and putting up a good fight. Her strength was described as inhuman. Help!
以及其他警察一起，协助芬尔森警官将萨比娜制服。总共花了大约六个人。但即便有这么多人压在她身上，她仍然在反抗并进行激烈的搏斗。她的力量被形容为非人类。救命啊！
Help! Help! Guys, watch it, guys. Wait, stop! Get down, we'll get an anchor up from behind. It's not this. Down. I'm going to find down.
救命！救命！伙计们，小心，伙计们。等等，停！趴下，我们从后面抓。不是这个。下去。我要找到下去。
I'm going to find you, snap. That way towards you. Watch it, face, watch it. Ah! Are they police? We are the police. Like her sister Ursula, Sabina also started calling out for the police.
我要找到你，咔嚓。那个方向朝向你。小心，脸，小心。啊！他们是警察吗？我们是警察。像她的姐姐乌苏拉一样，萨比娜也开始呼叫警察。
Despite the fact she was surrounded by police. No, let's go. Even when she was finally restrained, paramedics still weren't able to treat her, as she was still aggressive and still trying to fight. They ended up having to sedate her. Nobody had any idea what was going on. It was such bizarre behavior,
尽管她四周都是警察。不，我们走吧。甚至当她最终被制服时，急救人员仍无法对她进行治疗，因为她依然充满攻击性，还在试图反抗。他们最后不得不对她实施了镇静。没有人知道到底发生了什么。这是如此离奇的行为，
the likes of which the police on scene had never encountered before. They believed Ursula and Sabina were most likely off their heads on drugs. They also wondered if what they had just witnessed was the result of some sort of suicide pact the twins had made. A search of their bags found multiple mobile phones and a passport for one twin, but no idea at all for the other.
现场的警察从未遇到过。他们认为乌苏拉和萨比娜很可能是嗑药嗑嗨了。他们还怀疑他们刚刚目睹的是这对双胞胎达成的某种自杀协议的结果。对她们行李的搜查发现了多部手机和一个双胞胎中其中一人的护照，但完全没有另一个人的线索。
Both twins were transported to hospital. Ursula was in a critical condition. But Sabina was only suffering minor injuries and she was released after just five hours. Incredibly, a full psychiatric evaluation wasn't conducted. She was seen by a police doctor, a psych doctor and a social worker. And they all deemed that there was nothing wrong with her
这对双胞胎都被送往医院。乌苏拉处于危急状态。但萨比娜只受了轻伤，仅五小时后就被释放了。令人难以置信的是，当局并未对其进行全面的精神病评估。她接受了一名警医、一名精神科医生和一个社会工作者的检查。他们都认为她没有问题，
and she was fit to be released. Once she was released from hospital, police took her into their custody and transported her back to the station. The screaming, violent person throwing herself in front of traffic and fighting police was gone. Sabina was now calm, no trouble at all. It was that much of a change in behaviour
并且适合出院。一旦她从医院出院，警方便将她拘留并带回警察局。那个大喊大叫、暴力地把自己扔向车流并与警察搏斗的人已经消失了。萨比娜现在很平静，一点麻烦也没有。行为发生了如此大的变化，
that police transported her from the hospital without handcuffs. She sat in the back seat of their car, calm and totally unrestrained. Once they got back to the police station, Sabina even started laughing and joking around with the police. Part of what happens when processing a prisoner is the police ask a whole heap of questions about the prisoner's history and their health.
以至于警察在运送她离开医院时甚至没有给她戴手铐。她平静地坐在汽车后座上，完全没有受到任何束缚。一旦回到警察局，萨比娜甚至开始和警察有说有笑。处理犯人流程的一部分是警察会询问一堆关于犯人历史和健康的问题。
It's a duty of care. So police ask if they suffer from any illnesses, if they require medication, that sort of thing. They also ask if the prisoner has ever tried to harm themselves. When Sabina was asked this question, she said no, she hadn't. Whilst she was being processed, Sabina said these words,
这是尽到照顾义务。因此，警察会询问她们是否患有任何疾病，是否需要药物，诸如此类的事情。他们还会询问犯人是否曾试图伤害自己。当萨比娜被问到这个问题时，她回答说没有，她没有过。在办理手续时，萨比娜说出了这些话，
which would go on to be quite chilling. We say always in Sweden there's an accident, and rarely comes those. At least once more follows. We say always in Sweden that an accident rarely comes alone. Usually at least one more follows. Perhaps two.
这些话日后听来令人不寒而栗。我们在瑞典总是说，事故发生时，很少只有一次。至少还会有一次。我们在瑞典总是说，事故很少单独发生。通常至少还会发生一起。也许两起。
Sabina was charged with trespassing on a motorway and with assaulting a police officer. She had no previous criminal record. At no time during the process did Sabina ask how her sister was. She didn't mention her at all. She was very calm and casual about the whole thing. It was almost as if nothing had happened.
萨比娜被指控非法闯入高速公路和袭警。她没有前科。在整个过程中，萨比娜从未询问过她姐姐的情况。她根本没有提到她。她对整件事表现得非常平静和随意。就好像什么都没发生过一样。
There were no drugs found on Sabina or in her bag, same with Ursula. There was no evidence of drug use at all. As Ursula was in a critical condition at hospital, a blood sample was taken from her. Sure that something would show up, medical staff and police were surprised to find zero alcohol and zero traces of drugs in her system.
萨比娜身上或包里没有发现毒品，乌苏拉也是如此。根本没有吸毒的证据。由于乌苏拉在医院处于危急状态，医护人员提取了她的血液样本。坚信会有所发现的医护人员和警方惊讶地发现，她的体内酒精为零，毒品痕迹也为零。
A blood sample wasn't taken from Sabina. Suffering only minor injury, medical staff didn't have to take any. And only being charged with trespassing and assault, the police had no power to order the medical staff to take a blood sample. But given the negative result of Ursula's test, it's assumed Sabina's test also would have come back negative.
没有提取萨比娜的血液样本。由于只受了轻伤，医务人员无需提取。并且由于只被指控非法闯入和袭击，警方无权下令医务人员提取血液样本。但鉴于乌苏拉检测结果为阴性，可以推测萨比娜的检测结果同样会是阴性。
She was kept in custody and appeared at the Fenton Magistrates Court two days later, the 19th of May 2008. She played guilty to both charges. She was sentenced to one day in custody, which she had already served. So she was released. On that evening of Sabina's release,
她被拘留并在两天后的2008年5月19日出庭芬顿地方法院（Fenton Magistrates Court）。她对两项指控均认罪。她被判处在看守所服刑一天，由于她已经服刑完毕，因此她被释放了。就在萨比娜被释放的那天晚上，
the 19th of May 2008, Sabina crossed paths with 54-year-old Glenn Hollandshead and his friend Peter Malloy. They were walking home after having a few beers at the local pub. Glenn also had his dog with him. They were walking along Christchurch Street in Fenton when they noticed Sabina standing on the other side of the road. Peter says Sabina stuck out like a sore thumb.
2008年5月19日，萨比娜遇到了54岁的格伦·霍林斯黑德（Glenn Hollandshead）和他的朋友彼得·马洛伊（Peter Malloy）。他们在当地酒吧喝了几杯后正走在回家的路上。格伦还带了他的狗。当他们沿着芬顿的基督教堂街（Christchurch Street）行走时，他们注意到萨比娜站在马路对面。彼得说萨比娜显得格格不入。
She seemed stressed and worried and gave the impression she was lost. She was carrying her belongings in a plastic bag. Sabina shouted across the road at Glenn and Peter, saying it was a nice dog they had. Glenn and Peter made their way over and struck up a conversation with her. Sabina mentioned to them that her sister was in hospital
她看起来压力很大、很担忧，给人一种迷路了的印象。她用一个塑料袋装着自己的随身物品。萨比娜隔着马路向格伦和彼得喊话，说他们的狗很漂亮。格伦和彼得走了过去，并与她搭话。萨比娜向他们提到她的姐姐在医院里，
and that she was trying to find her. The conversation went on a little further before Sabina said she needed to find a bed and breakfast to stay at. Glenn told her there was really nowhere around the area where she could stay, but she was welcome to go back to Hesias. He said he would give her something to eat and then they could try and work out where her sister was
她正试图找到她。谈话持续了一会儿，之后萨比娜说她需要找一家住宿加早餐旅馆过夜。格伦告诉她附近真的没有什么地方可以让她留宿，但她欢迎去海西亚斯（Hesias，应为Hesleys的误听或地名）家。他说他会给她一些吃的，然后他们可以设法弄清楚她姐姐在哪里，
and then they could organise somewhere for her to stay. Peter says this was just in Glenn's character. He was a good Samaritan and liked to help people in need. He was a very warm and friendly type of person. Sabina accepted the offer. She then seemed to open up a bit more and become warmer and friendlier. They got back to Glenn's house and sat down
然后他们可以为她安排一个住处。彼得说这完全符合格伦的性格。他是一个好撒玛利亚人，喜欢帮助有需要的人。他是一个非常热情和友好的人。萨比娜接受了这个提议。她随后似乎变得更加开放，更加热情和友好。他们回到格伦的家里坐下来，
and had a few drinks together. When Glenn and Peter asked about Sabina's sister, her demeanour would change. There would either be an awkward silence or she would quickly change the subject. Sabina also started to display some odd paranoid behaviour. They would be sitting down talking and then she would get up and walk over to the window,
一起喝了几杯。当格伦和彼得询问关于萨比娜姐姐的情况时，她的态度就会改变。要么会出现尴尬的沉默，要么她会迅速转移话题。萨比娜还开始表现出一些奇怪的偏执行为。他们坐着聊天，然后她会站起来走到窗前，
pull the shades up, stare up and down the street before snapping the shades back and sitting down again. She did this a few times as if she was paranoid somebody was watching. Then she got out her cigarettes and asked Glenn and Peter if they wanted one. They both accepted. As they were both about to light up,
拉起百叶窗，上下打量着街道，然后猛地拉下百叶窗，又坐了下来。她这样做了好几次，就好像有谁在监视她一样。然后她掏出香烟，问格伦和彼得要不要抽一根。两人都接受了。正当他们俩准备点烟时，
Sabina quickly snatched the cigarettes back off them and said, they might be poisoned, you can't have them. Despite the fact Sabina had been smoking from this particular packet of cigarettes all night. Peter was starting to feel very uneasy. He could tell something wasn't quite right with Sabina. Glenn on the other hand didn't seem concerned at all. He was kicking back, relaxed and comfortable.
萨比娜迅速把香烟从他们手里抢了回去，并说：“它们可能有毒，你们不能抽。”尽管事实上萨比娜整晚都在抽这包特定的香烟。彼得开始感到非常不安。他看出萨比娜有些不对劲。而格伦则显得一点也不担心。他往后靠着，放松而舒适。
He kept telling Peter not to worry, saying Sabina was just a bit quirky, nothing to be concerned about. But Peter couldn't get out of there soon enough. He left the house and went home, leaving Sabina and Glenn there by themselves. Perhaps what was most intriguing is that despite being run over by a car,
他一直告诉彼得不要担心，说萨比娜只是有点古怪，没什么好担心的。但彼得恨不得马上离开那里。他离开了房子回家了，把萨比娜和格伦留在那里。也许最耐人寻味的是，尽管两天前刚被汽车撞飞，
flung up into the air and slamming onto the road, two heavy impacts knocking her unconscious only two days before, Sabina wasn't complaining of any pain at all. She seemed completely unaffected. Around lunchtime the next day, Glenn rung his brother Paul, who worked at the local hospital. He was trying to find out some more information on Ursula.
高高抛起并重重摔在路上，遭受了两次导致她失去知觉的重击，萨比娜却没有抱怨任何疼痛。她似乎完全没有受到影响。第二天午饭前后，格伦给在当地医院工作的弟弟保罗打了电话。他试图找到关于乌苏拉的更多信息。
Paul said Glenn was his usual cheerful self, no alarm bells at all. He could hear Sabina's voice in the background. Glenn explained to his brother what had happened and said they were just after any information they could get on Ursula. About 7.40pm that evening, Glenn walked outside and asked a neighbour, Frank Booth, if he had any spare teabags.
保罗说格伦和平时一样开朗，一点警报也没有。他能听到背景里萨比娜的声音。格伦向弟弟解释了发生的事情，并说他们只是在寻找关于乌苏拉的任何信息。那天晚上7点40分左右，格伦走到户外，问邻居弗兰克·布思（Frank Booth）有没有多余的茶包。
Frank was outside washing his vehicle and told Glenn that when he finished up, he would go in and grab some. Glenn thanked him and walked back inside his house. But only one minute later he was back outside. Staggering, suffering from four stab wounds, including one to the heart. He said to Frank,
弗兰克正在外面洗车，告诉格伦他忙完后就进去拿一些。格伦向他道谢，然后走回屋里。但仅仅一分钟后他又回到了外面。步履蹒跚，身受四处刀伤，其中一处在心脏。他对弗兰克说，
I've been stabbed, she's stabbed me. He then collapsed to the ground. Frank immediately dialed emergency services, which is triple nine in the UK. As this was happening, Glenn asked Frank to look after his dog. He then passed away. Meanwhile, Sabina left Glentius
我被刺伤了，她刺了我。随后他瘫倒在地。弗兰克立即拨打了紧急求救电话，即英国的999。在发生这一切的同时，格伦请弗兰克照顾他的狗。随后他去世了。与此同时，萨比娜离开了格伦的家，
and ran up the street carrying a hammer. She was in a completely deranged state, hitting herself over the head with the hammer. This caught the attention of a passing motorist Joshua, who saw what she was doing and saw that her hair was matted with blood. She also had blood over the front of her jacket. Joshua got out of his car
手里拿着一把锤子顺着街道跑去。她处于完全疯狂的状态，用锤子猛击自己的头部。这引起了一名路过的司机约书亚（Joshua）的注意，他看到了她的所作所为，并看到她的头发被血黏在一起。她夹克的前面也沾满了血。约书亚下了车，
and tried to wrestle the hammer from Sabina. Sabina struggled with him and seemed to be in an absolute rage. Sabina got the better of Joshua by hitting him in the back of the head with a broken piece of roof tile that she was carrying in her pocket. Sabina got away.
试图从萨比娜手中夺下锤子。萨比娜与他搏斗，显得怒不可遏。萨比娜用她口袋里带着的一块破屋顶瓦片砸向约书亚的后脑勺，占了上风。萨比娜逃脱了。
Joshua saw two paramedic vehicles driving after her. They had obviously responded to the call and driven across Sabina. Sabina continued running, trying to get away from the paramedics. She ran to a bridge at Heron Cross, above the A-50 roadway. Sabina climbed the railing
约书亚看到两辆急救车向她追去。他们显然是响应了报警并遇到了萨比娜。萨比娜继续奔跑，试图躲避急救人员。她跑到了A-50公路上方赫伦克罗斯（Heron Cross）的一座桥上。萨比娜爬上栏杆，
and jumped straight off onto the road below. The fall was about 30 feet, which is about 10 metres. She broke both of her ankles and fractured her skull. But again, she survived. She was transported to hospital for treatment. Meanwhile, police examined the crime scene at Glentius.
直接跳下了下方的公路。跌落高度约为30英尺，即大约10米。她摔断了双脚踝，颅骨骨折。但她还是活了下来。她被送往医院接受治疗。与此同时，警察对格伦家进行了犯罪现场勘查。
It looked as though Glent was in the process of preparing a meal when he had been stabbed. Sabina's DNA profile was found on the kitchen knife used to stab Glent. Her bloodstained jacket and a ring she was wearing contained matching DNA from Glent. Sabina remained in hospital until September. Upon being discharged from hospital,
看起来格伦遇刺时正在准备饭菜。在刺死格伦的厨房刀具上发现了萨比娜的DNA样本。她沾满血迹的夹克和她戴的一枚戒指上含有与格伦相匹配的DNA。萨比娜在医院呆到了9月。出院后，
she was charged with the murder of Glent Holland's head. Her cellar was also discharged from hospital in September. But she wasn't charged with any offences. She was allowed to return to Sweden. Sabina refused to answer any questions at all. Every question that was asked of her, she replied, no comment. So we have no idea exactly what happened in Glentius
她被控谋杀格伦·霍林斯黑德。她的细胞（注：应为Cellular或译为指其双胞胎姐姐，此处可能原文有误或口误，通常指Ursula）也在9月出院。但她没有受到任何指控。她被允许返回瑞典。萨比娜拒绝回答任何问题。对她提出的每一个问题，她都回答：“无可奉告。”因此我们完全不知道那天在格伦家究竟发生了什么，甚至连彼得离开后当晚发生的事也不知道。
that day or even the night before after Peter had left. Sabina pleaded not guilty to murder and a trial date was set for February 2009. But it was postponed due to issues getting Sabina's medical records. The trial was rescheduled for September 2009. But the case never ended up going to trial. Instead, she was able to plead guilty to a lesser charge. Prior to the trial, Sabina was charged with a murder.
萨比娜对谋杀指控不认罪，审判日期定于2009年2月。但由于获取萨比娜医疗记录方面的问题，审判被推迟了。审判重新安排在2009年9月。但该案最终并未进入审判阶段。相反，她得以对较轻的指控认罪。在审判之前，萨比娜被指控谋杀。
Sabina was charged with a murder. Prior to the trial, Sabina was assessed by two forensic psychiatrists, one acting for the defense and the other one acting for the prosecution. They both reached the same conclusion. Sabina was mentally ill at the time she killed Glent Holland's head. But they had different opinions on what the mental illness was.
萨比娜被指控谋杀。在审判前，萨比娜接受了两名法医精神病学家的评估，一名代表辩方，另一名代表控方。他们得出了相同的结论。萨比娜在杀死格伦·霍林斯黑德时患有精神疾病。但他们对这种精神疾病是什么有不同的看法。
The defense diagnosed Sabina with induced delusional disorder. A basic meaning is madness in two people. So what they were saying is that one person suffers from a psychotic illness. And then the second person becomes affected by it and they end up taking on the psychosis as well. For example, Ursula runs out onto the motorway into the path of a truck. So Sabina follows. Both conditions were extremely rare.
辩方诊断萨比娜患有诱发性妄想症。基本意思是两个人的疯狂。所以他们所说的是，一个人患有精神病性疾病。然后第二个人受到影响，最终也患上了这种精神病。例如，乌苏拉跑上高速公路冲向卡车车道。于是萨比娜跟了上去。这两种情况都极其罕见。
And Glent's family wanted to know why Sabina was released from hospital so soon and allowed to go free after the motorway incident if she was suffering from what was now determined to be a psychotic episode. Prior to Sabina's release from hospital after the motorway incident, she was seen by a police surgeon, a psychiatrist and a social worker. These aren't police officers. They are medical professionals.
格伦的家人想知道，如果萨比娜患有现在被确定为精神病发作的疾病，为什么她在高速公路事件后这么快就被释放出院并被允许自由。在高速公路事件后萨比娜出院之前，她接受了一名警察外科医生、一名精神科医生和一个社会工作者的检查。这些人不是警察。他们是医疗专业人员。
And they all came to the conclusion that Sabina displayed no obvious signs of any mental or psychological illness. They all concluded she was fit and well to be released. They didn't have the benefit of seeing the footage when they came to that conclusion but they would have had detailed accounts from the officers who were there of what went on. It's pretty amazing that they did come to that conclusion. A couple of explanations have been thrown up. If she was in fact suffering from a puff of madness,
他们都得出结论，萨比娜没有表现出任何明显的精神或心理疾病迹象。他们都得出结论认为她健康状况良好，可以出院。他们在得出这个结论时没有看到事发现场的录像，但他们应该从在场的警官那里得到了关于所发生事情的详细描述。他们竟然得出那样的结论，真是令人惊叹。人们提出了几种解释。如果她实际上患有一阵疯狂，
then the psychotic behavior can come and go quickly. So it may have been gone momentarily at the time she was assessed. Another theory is that maybe the sedation she was given on the motorway was still having a bit of a calming effect on her at the time she was assessed. Either way, the system failed. The murder charge was dropped and Sabina was allowed to enter a play of guilty to manslaughter on the grounds of diminished responsibility.
那么精神病行为可以来得快去得也快。因此在她接受评估时，这种状态可能已经暂时消失了。另一种理论是，她在高速公路上被注射的镇静剂在她接受评估时可能仍在对她产生某种平静的效果。无论如何，系统失败了。谋杀指控被撤销，萨比娜被允许以减弱责任为由对过失杀人罪认罪。
The judge accepting that Sabina had suffered from a rare and temporary form of insanity at the time of the murder. During the court process, Sabina maintained a silence about what had happened. She didn't utter a single word about the murder of Glen Hollinshead or the motorway incident. No one had any idea what the twins were even doing in England in the first place. They have never given a reason. The judge had a difficult time determining
法官接受了萨比娜在谋杀发生时患有一种罕见且暂时的精神失常形式的说法。在法院审理过程中，萨比娜对发生的事情保持沉默。她没有说出关于谋杀格伦·霍林斯黑德或高速公路事件的哪怕一个字。没有人知道这对双胞胎一开始在英国到底在做什么。她们从未给出过原因。法官很难确定
exactly what diagnosis of Sabina was the correct one, as a strong case could be made for both. It was made more difficult by the fact that neither of the forensic psychiatrists had assessed Ursula. Maybe if she had been assessed, they could have gotten some piece of information that could have shed a bit more light on Pinks. Another issue arose with the case when both the defence and the prosecution agreed that although Sabina was mentally ill at the time of the murder,
究竟哪种对萨比娜的诊断是正确的，因为双方都有充分的理由。由于两位法医精神病学家都没有评估过乌苏拉，这使得事情变得更加困难。也许如果她接受了评估，他们就能得到一些能对事件提供更多光亮的信息。案件还出现了另一个问题，当辩方和控方都同意，尽管萨比娜在谋杀时患有精神疾病，
she had now made a full recovery. So what that meant was that the judge couldn't send her to a secure mental health hospital because she was no longer mentally ill. So instead, he wanted to give Sabina a sentence with no fixed release date to make sure she would only be freed when it was safe to do so. But he could only do that if Sabina was considered a risk to the public. And both the defence and the prosecution's psychiatrists agreed that they considered Sabina to only be a low risk.
但她现在已经完全康复了。这意味着法官不能将她送往安全的精神病院，因为她不再患有精神疾病。因此，他希望判处萨比娜一个没有固定释放日期的刑期，以确保她只有在安全时才能被释放。但他只有在萨比娜被认为对公众构成风险时才能这样做。而辩方和控方的精神病学家都一致认为，他们认为萨比娜只具有低风险。
With that, the judge said his hands were tied. Given she was determined to be low risk, by law, the judge had to give her a fixed term prison sentence with no supervision or monitoring requirements after her release. He sentenced her to five years jail. Glenn's family considered Sabina's diagnosis to be a pretty convenient one. A quick and easy way to deal with the case, because really, no one had any idea what was going on, it was so bizarre.
话虽如此，法官表示他的手被绑住了。鉴于她被确定为低风险，根据法律，法官必须判处她有期徒刑，刑期固定，且在她释放后没有监督或监测要求。他判处她五年监禁。格伦的家人认为萨比娜的诊断是一个非常方便的诊断。处理此案的一种快速简便的方法，因为说实话，没有人知道到底发生了什么，它是如此离奇。
Here is what the judge, Justice Saunders, had to say at sentencing. I understand that this sentence will seem entirely inadequate to the relatives of the deceased. However, I have sentenced on the basis that the reason for the killing was the mental illness, and therefore the culpability of the defendant was low. And therefore the sentence I have passed is designed to protect the public. It is not designed to reflect the grief the relatives have suffered, or to measure the value of Mr. Hollins head's life. No sentence that I could pass could do that.
以下是法官桑德斯（Justice Saunders）在宣判时的发言。我理解这个判决对死者家属来说会显得完全不够。然而，我的判决依据是，谋杀的原因是精神疾病，因此被告的罪责很低。因此我所做出的判决旨在保护公众。它并不是为了反映家属所遭受的悲伤，也不是为了衡量霍林斯黑德先生生命的价值。我能做出的任何判决都无法做到这一点。
It is a sentence which I hope fairly measures a truly tragic event. Sabina only served two and a half years of her sentence, and then she was released and she was allowed to return to Sweden. Just like her life before these incidents, very little is known about Sabina since her release. With either condition she was thought to be suffering from, there is a possibility Sabina could relapse into another episode of Insanity in the future. Thank you for watching. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这是一个我希望公平衡量真正悲惨事件的判决。萨比娜只服刑了两年半就被释放了，并被允许返回瑞典。就像她在这些事件之前的生活一样，自从她被释放后，人们对萨比娜知之甚少。无论她被认为患有哪种疾病，萨比娜未来都有可能再次陷入精神失常的发作中。感谢收看。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。